guys it finally came it's a little bit
late but i finally got my copy of the
metroid dread special edition and we're
gonna unbox it right now
people of the internet retro racking
tour here
i'm a huge metroid fan and i have been
so
eagerly anticipating the special edition
i almost didn't get it actually got my
order in kind of last minute walmart had
a couple of others that opened up
and oh my goodness would you look at
this
okay
first reaction
this is way bigger than it was made to
appear in screenshots
way bigger i can't believe this it is
taking up this entire
box i mean good packing here right at
the top all we had was this little
bubble wrap here then i'm just gonna go
ahead and let's see if i can kind of
just slide it out does it go that deep
too
no okay there's there's another uh
set of bubble wrap underneath but dude
look at this
i cannot believe
i don't know maybe it's just something
weird with how it appeared online see
just the uh order form there more bubble
wrap nothing else
toss that to the side here
and oh my goodness i can't get over this
i really can't you've got this really
nice
outer
cover it's kind of got that raised
texture right here on samus and also on
metroid here
and then on the back we've got some more
excellent artwork dude look at that look
at that
man if you guys are new to the channel
uh you may not know how big of a metroid
fan i am some people have been asking me
have i started playing it yet i actually
haven't started playing it because i've
been so
eagerly anticipating
this special edition but it came a
little bit late but that's okay because
i was away for the weekend anyway
so on the top here you just have kind of
this little piece of tape right here
popped off very easily so i'm going to
go ahead and slide this open and i'll
get some comparison shots here before i
wrap up we'll have some b-roll so you
guys can see just how big this thing is
in case it doesn't come across
i mean the pictures made it look like
just a slightly
larger than the the switch game box
really
all right let's be very careful with
this i'll open it this way here so you
guys can
get a little bit better of a view here
okay i'm going to slide it very
carefully i don't want the whole thing
to fly out
there we go yeah i am definitely hanging
on to that box though that is a an
excellent box to keep
okay then here on top we have
i think this is the steel book here
and then we've got what looks like i
think this is the art
cards so we'll crack those open here in
a bit but first i want to take a look
at the steel book so i'm guessing this
is the
kind of the the game case instead
go ahead and open it up here yes and
there it is
metroid dread
so no instruction manual or anything
like that just a copy of the game and
the steel book so this feels you know
this is like a normal switch box right
here so you have that normal switch box
compared to
this is what uh it came in
so we're gonna sit this to the side here
oops let's see put that right there
and then oh my goodness i gotta see what
this is though
i gotta check out dude this is the art
book
the art book this is massive
yeah i don't know if it's like the
product shots or what but
or maybe it's just my perspective was
off but look from looking at the product
shots online i did not get the idea that
it was going to be this large at all so
that's the reason that the box is so big
is for this art book right here so it
does have like a little plastic wrap on
it let's go ahead and take that off here
toss that to the side with the box
and so then we also have kind of the the
text that sort of has that texture to it
sticks out a little bit got sort of a
matte black finish here i don't know if
that's going to come through on camera
let's see if i get there we go tilt it
just right sort of this matte black
finish here and then a bit of a shinier
texture on the corners there
same thing actually for the back it is
mostly the glossy look there we go a
little bit of the matte look right there
all right let's take a look obviously
not gonna go through the entire art book
here but maybe we will at another time
so what i heard online is that not only
is this artwork okay yeah here we go
it's not only from metroid dread it is
artwork from the entire
metroid series so we have the very first
metroid right here this is going to be a
really fun book to go through i think we
might have to do a completely
separate video just detailing some of
the artwork in here let's kind of flip
through the back see if we can just get
a
kind of a quick look at maybe some of
the metroid dread stuff yeah i think i
think this is definitely metroid dread
at this point here don't want to spoil
anything since i haven't played the game
yet
but uh that's got to be oh we know what
that one is right there that's
definitely metroid fusion metroid fusion
right there i love that aqua color of
samus suit there all right well let's
set the art book aside so we got the art
book we've got the
steelbook for the game here it's always
kind of annoying one thing that always
bothers me when you get the the
collector's editions is that
you don't get a copy of the regular box
as well so when this is like sitting on
the shelf you don't have that maybe it's
just my pet peeve i don't know but you
don't have the metroid dread on the
spine there
i i buy digital a lot more these days
anyway but it's just kind of one of
those little annoying things right come
on include include a copy of the of the
standard box as well and then finally we
have what appears to be the i think
these are like art cards or something so
let's see if this
plastic wrap comes off pretty easily or
if i need some scissors
yeah there we go not too bad
we'll go ahead and toss that to the side
as well
and if you guys are interested in
purchasing this you might want to keep
an eye out because
a lot of times what happens is when it
actually releases they will get some
cancellation so i actually didn't
pre-order it at all
and then
kind of had sort of written off ever
getting one and then saw some tweets
online that it was back in stock and i
actually saw it pop up at several
different retailers i got mine from
walmart but i did see it pop up on
amazon and i think target and maybe best
buy as well but definitely keep an eye
out for that so here we have it says
metroid on the front there
and then we have the first arc card here
we will probably go through these so
there's the the original metroid right
there
and then you have metroid 2 return of
samus which was for the game boy yeah it
even says right there
right there at the top
get that to focus there for you yep game
boy
oh man super metroid one
oh i love it
i love it the iconic shot
samus and ridley
see if i can tilt that down a little bit
so you guys don't have that glare on
there from my my light
yeah that's that's uh that's actually
the box art right i think from super
metroid
then we have metroid fusion
which was for the aforementioned game
boy advance
love those colors love the colors of
metroid fusion i haven't played that one
in a long time oh man no metroid prime
come on i guess it's all of the
side scrolling metroid's that they
feature here
and then you have the card for metroid
dread
very nice very nice all right so let's
put all of those cards back in
and i don't want to bend any of them
so i'm going to make sure i got to be
very careful here don't want to bend any
of these as i put them back inside their
little their little sleeve that it comes
in so yeah that looks like that is
everything you get
with the metroid red special edition
[Music]
you get the steel book of course with
the game a really really nice art book i
did not expect the art book to be
this large that's going to be a lot of
fun going through that and checking out
all of that metroid artwork and then the
uh the little metroid cards here so
really my only complaint is that i do
wish you still got a copy of the
standard box for the game i always think
that's kind of weird that more games
don't do that but hey it's uh it's kind
of a premium case and the artwork on the
on the steelbook is pretty nice as well
so guys if you're interested in
purchasing metroid dread check out the
affiliate link in the description
again if you're wanting the special
edition though
you're going to have to really keep an
eye out on on various stock websites and
see if you can get lucky there but can't
wait to dive in stay tuned for the let's
plays which are certainly coming from
metroid red as always thank you all so
much for watching and i will talk to you
again soon
you